I'm gonna play for you something
horribly irresponsible Fox News Dr Mark
Siegel went on Tucker Carlson's show
last night and in a sort of final Salvo
to try to hurt John fetterman said John
Federman is either going to have another
stroke while in office or even will die
in office he says he's statistically
he's not going to survive a six-year
term as Senator as many of you may know
Oz versus fetterman Pennsylvania Senate
race John fetterman suffered a stroke
some months ago everything that we have
seen from his doctors and everything we
can glean from when we see fetterman
writing for example it's abundantly
clear that he is cognitively fine
however the stroke has left them with a
deficit in terms of auditory processing
converting things that he hears
into meaningful messages instantly the
way we all do and turning what he wants
to say into a coherent speech he
sometimes struggles with that and Mark
Siegel went on and said this this guy's
not even going to survive a term and
I'll tell you in a moment where where
the information is coming from and of
course remember that Mark Siegel is not
fetterman's doctor he is not well
positioned to really comment on this and
setterman himself has said that his
stroke was due to a blood clot from the
heart that is very significant Tucker
because a study out of a journal called
stroke very prominent Journal looking at
over 6 000 people from Great Britain
have found that if your blood clot comes
from the heart you have about less than
a 60 percent a sixty percent chance more
than a sixty percent chance of either
not living five years or having another
stroke within those five years it's
greater than sixty percent chance so I
say to the voters of Pennsylvania
tonight who are ready to check a box
tomorrow yeah he's he's a doctor but
he's telling voters how to vote okay I
think before you check a box you should
consider a statistic like that greater
than 60 chance that someone like
fetterman with a heart in his condition
having had a stroke will either have a
recurrence or won't survive the term
okay so sucker
it's like why not just I mean this
happened in may they had time to put a
real candidate in it okay so let's go
through this first of all imagine if CNN
did a segment like this
about any Republican just just just
imagine what would be happening if they
did that that's number one secondly
where did the doctor get this
information I don't know he talks about
a British study
I was not able to find that study the
study I was able to find on stroke
survival rates is from Denmark and it
did not include 6 000 people it included
5 000 people and it included 5 000
people who suffered Strokes between 1982
and 1991. so first and foremost it's a
period that started 40 years ago and
ended 30 years ago so right away we
should be saying okay has stroke
treatment and Recovery improved in the
last 30 to 40 years and the answer is
absolutely so if again we we don't know
what study he's talking about this is
the study I found
indeed that study does say your risk of
death increases to 60 percent
in the five years following certain
types of Strokes for this group who
suffered Strokes between 1982 and 1991.
now the problem with assessing fetterman
in this way is that the mortality is
overwhelmingly skewed to people in their
80s followed by people in their 70s
followed by people in their 60s okay so
fetterman's 53. so right away you've got
to take that 60 and say this was based
on treatment 30 to 40 years ago
the mortality is heavily skewed to the
80 70 and 60 year olds okay
but what's the most important thing here
the most important thing is that this is
a very dangerous road to go down if you
want to just play statistical games let
me explain Chuck Grassley senator from
Iowa up for re-election he's 89 years
old
How likely is it remember folks we're
we're just looking at the numbers facts
don't care about your feelings
statistically
89 year old men once you make it to 89
years old as a man in the United States
you're likely to live four more years
and the Senate term is six years
statistically you can say what Siegel is
saying about fetterman about Grassley
Grassley why is anyone how is this guy
they should have put a real candidate up
grassly statistically won't survive a
term he will die in office if we elect
him why is no one talking about that
the reality is these people know there's
no rational reason not to vote for
fetterman there just isn't Oz isn't even
really from Pennsylvania he's a [ __ ]
he's a quack TV Doctor he's a
flip-flopper but not because his views
have genuinely changed for good factual
reasons it's because he's putting his
finger to the political winds so they go
after fetterman's character and they go
after fetterman's Health in a way where
listen if we want to play an Actuarial
game there's a hell of a lot of
Republicans who you should not be
electing because statistically they are
not likely to survive a six-year Senate
term these people are pathetic and just
imagine for a second imagine for a
second how they would be reacting
if CNN did this about a republican
candidate uh we'll have this clip and
other clips from today's show on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show you can also find my personal
Instagram there by searching for
david.pakman before you go if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description